[Music]
congratulations you are pregnant with
your second shot that's right how far
along are you
we're getting into it you know we're
past the scary part we're into our
second trimester and you know I'm
feeling good I love being pregnant
because I love getting a chance to gain
weight right you know I mean it's
actually you're just like your job to
gain weight yeah that's that's my
mission right now I wake up the morning
I go to the fridge and I'm like let's do
this I'm like baked like New York crumb
cakes and bacon cheeseburgers and allow
myself to indulge on all the things that
I don't really get when I'm not you know
it's when I met my wife when we were
dating she was a vegetarian and she had
been a vegetarian for years and years
and years and then we get married and
then she's pregnant and I remembered I
was in a restaurant and I'm eating a
hamburger a rare hamburger and she's
just staring at the hamburger and she
went can I have a bite and I said you
know ya think you do not get in the way
of a woman and oh yeah when she is
hungry it's absolutely fantastic how do
you feel I feel so good I feel so good
it's just really exciting you know I'm
happy to be done working a little bit
and you know - do you have that thing
where this will drive my wife crazy and
I think it drives a lot of women crazy
there are these there's a kind of guy
that thinks he's entitled just be like
you're pregnant
I feel the belly yes they don't ask
permission
they don't have seen people do it all
the time no you can't do that I'm
fondled all the time yeah people come up
to you in the supermarket I mean I'll
tell you one of the nice things about
showing now and being out is that you
can reap the benefits of it because
people are so sweet to you when you are
pregnant one of the bad things you don't
touch you all the time the other things
people open the door for you they feed
you they think you're tired right you
know you have no guilt and just laying
and reading magazines and watching TV
there's pros and cons yeah now so many
celebrities in this town talk about they
want a natural birth they got home birth
they want a natural birth that's in the
water all these things that's that
that seemed a little unconventional is
that something that you're interested in
with my first son Teddy I had this huge
dream of being able to do a natural
birth because I admire these moms that
can do it
it sounds so amazing so we spent like
you know all the pregnancy doing hypno
birthing me my husband he was so patient
with me
and then hypno what hypno birthing you
like talk to the baby and listen to like
bells chiming and like you know I was
into it I was like I'm gonna do this
this is the right way no no get a drug
man well I have a very low tolerance for
pain and I didn't remember that and my
dad reminded me that when I was 13 I got
my ears pierced and I only got one done
because I couldn't handle the pain and
you want to have a natural childbirth it
was ridiculous I wasted a year of my
life
so yeah well so this time around the
plans a little different absolutely
natural childbirth is not happening in
this lifetime for me I want to mention
this
you wrote a cooking book kitchen revelry
a year of festive menus from my home to
yours you like you really love cooking
and you like having parties I do we
throw parties all the time in our house
I mean for me it's like one of the
things like you know I have a busy week
I still want to get out the heirloom
tomatoes and the burrata and like cook
up a storm it's just like great passion
of mine I just order a pizza for
everybody and then I make them pay I bet
you serve great line who had more than
one slice I serve a good boxed wine
that's my method
you